like let's grab one each you can pull
about the same time to get it yeah hello
and welcome to Adam and James play video
games I am indeed
Adam and I'm joined by James hello this
is me waving right this guy this bald
guy here needs a new brain and we have
it in this jar and I think the best way
to do that is definitely gonna be with a
hammer with a hammer I'm okay with that
Oh actually it fears to be more of an
axe this time oh my word you got a hot
chick there's a good cushion right right
it's ready for your doctor there you go
it's all yours
okay I'm still you recognize I'll go
around the edge a little bit maybe the
sword wasn't the best idea
all right first time brilliant just died
yes feel my thumb right just a bit right
I'm giving up on that song as these
seconds from death well stab ourselves
with it yeah where is it is it the blue
one it would green one we used before
it's not mr. Behrman damn - yeah at this
point maybe cut the ring get by the bat
right okay Kurama yes yes right what am
i doing - just shove it we're gonna try
well I believe he's an eye transplant it
looks like it yes which let's take one I
each shall we like that's a really good
way right let's have a look at the
patient is it still Johnson or John
Cena's looking good and your are I do
it's gonna be my I think I've goggles on
it we're doing it that's a good point
that's a really good point what was he
looking at as well can you take his mask
off or cracked him yeah I think she's
glasses yes let me see your eyes he
still can't see it
yeah I'll see ya Oh
oh my god it's in there gone you can do
this I'll tell you forgot the wrong one
no pressure you losing eight milliliters
a second you you try and give him that
and I'll try and cure us okay deal Oh
drop that that's gone wrong oh I've got
it
okay this will kill you Hey oh well done
I've got this now kill him
dump down I won't stop that's it oh you
just dropped my tool off the table I'm
sorry alright so Oh what happened oh
he's growing
in the dig and again 15 mil 10 mil 5
there we go right
cut get that thing off his head what
[ __ ] he's got what then put that there
have you got one of his eyes out
I reckon hammer to the face I've got his
eyes here can you put him in the ditch
that's amazing
I led because I'm a boss boom I've got
more eyes Cheers
what to save why snap use a laser can I
turn it excuse me sir
those are strong classes look now cuz I
call myself
oh just gonna stab you in the eye oh it
looks head is moving a bit we're gonna
push it back in that's good that's good
oh we look tweezers yes
tweezers
right here going through this never got
much time he's losing blood he's lost
touch Anita to leave the chavista to
peace can we grab them we just write
yank em out how's that not gone that so
should have gone all waste coming off
there in it tendons and [ __ ] tendons in
she'd yes